we begin this half hour with the soaring
prices that we are all seeing at the
pump just ahead of the summer driving
season the national average for a gallon
of gasoline
4.59 as of friday that is 16 cents
higher than this time last week and much
higher than the 304
we were paying this time last year
inflation the war in ukraine supply
chain issues coupled with rising demand
are all factors in the steep prices but
there is more to it michael george is
here to explain michael good morning
dana good morning there is a lot of
finger pointing about who's to blame for
the high gasoline prices republicans
blame the bide administration democrats
say the oil companies are price gouging
but analysts say the root of the problem
is actually more complex
certainly along with the spike in prices
at the pump
refineries and oil companies profits
have spiked too in the first three
months of the year chevron's profits
rose 33 percent over the last three
months of 2021. shells jumped 42 percent
conoco phillips is up 43 percent and
british petroleum's profits soared 51
percent
oil companies are making a lot of money
by going along for the ride they're
selling their oil at the market price
professor severon borenstein of
berkeley's energy institute points out
that oil and gas production is caught in
a tangled mess compounded by the fact
that there are two percent more vehicles
on the road than there were before the
pandemic most of the increase has come
from crude oil prices going up and
that's because world demand has been
coming back quite strongly from the
pandemic
and supply hasn't caught up even before
russia attacked ukraine
we were seeing the production of oil
lagging
producers in the united states are
reporting they're having a hard time
getting workers to come back to the oil
fields they're having
supply chain problems with parts and
equipment
hinged wallets also present a challenge
we don't go out as much with the car
my wife and i were kind of old farts but
we've been riding our bicycles but there
may be a lot more time to practice
before prices come down the reality is
we are in for high gas prices certainly
through the summer and probably through
the end of this year
possibly gradually going lower
but we're not going to see
two dollar or three dollar gasoline even
in the near future
now there are early indications that
more oil and gas workers will be back in
the fields and that'll help increase
domestic production now as for the
millions of barrels of russian oil loss
per day it's anyone's guess when that
will change but what can change are
americans driving habits ridership on
mass transit is way down it's less than
half that it was before the pandemic i
get people are concerned but this is the
one way to cut back absolutely roads are
packed yeah packed right now michael
thank you really good information